listen up dos nobody paid for nearly the
entire universe has been destroyed who's
to blame for san Cisco now souls the
last door is a dangerous stratification
do we put a stop to it but you're going
to eat guns like these and these meet
some muscle kick serious ass I say
muscle i mean like dirt dude took a
solid rockets or look at vampires no
flying luchador Peggy Sue whatever if we
take a week you're dead so join the
pound for today by each other no
response a class are you forever know
that you must how we needed you most
pretty amazing right did you even read
the cue cards you skipped all the best
parts Eve old the universe once lit by
countless stars nowadays is not so much
what's worse the few stars still burning
have all been dragged screaming into the
boy by this handsome vampire clothes are
renting
and legions of extra dimensional horrors
of RLC now they're coming for solace the
last star in the universe you're
probably thinking gosh isn't there
another way Keith there is join us we
are the last light consortium and when
we're not economically subjugating
systems throughout the galaxy we're
bringing them hurt to read gain and his
for LC master
as a car carrying battleborn you can
embark on mission solo or you can bring
along some only to die alongside you did
I say die I meant succeed and save the
star and everybody is happy forever but
in its endless pursuit of profit the LLC
also heavily in versus bloody
territorial combat between off again on
again in chapter you'll square off
against other battle for to seize
control of energy collectors expect
these fights to be fast paced brutal and
action-packed in belltown guilty guiding
adorable lift robots each of their own
hopes and dreams to their grisly death
sacrifice more robust than your
opponents to curry favor with the
arbiter of robot be cycling men wreck
and escape his wrath your efforts have
pleased minaret in a universe with only
one star and a handful of an
double world's the real estate market is
just bonkers an incursion you'll stake
your claim on these words protect your
HQ and fight for every inch of Dera
firma while you seize your enemy's base
yes sir we are drawing deep and
opportunity at the last night consortium
but thatís Ria's only half the story
fighting earns you cold hard cash but
everyone who fights for solace is
compensated handsomely Kell stop earn
credits use those credits to buy fancy
new duds cybernetic upgrades and even
inappropriate gestures whoa well that's
our just shoot dudes house cuz anyway
but wait there's more have I mentioned
the latest and greatest in compulsory
invasive genetic modification let's say
a fella only knew what some of those
words meant explain the rest of them
okay and rebound born badass isn't it
with an LLC brand helix rig these little
beauties can be played your genetic bio
weapons on the fly and they're powered
by and drop violence they ensure that
every combat encounter is as new and
accelerating as the first day you step
foot on the battlefield in exchange for
all these sweet benefits you will hurl
yourself headlong into the gaping maw
under death itself Chuck but you don't
have to do it alone oh ah that's why for
the first time the LLC is reaching out
to all the denizens of sauron regardless
of prior fashion Allah Billy
that means no matter where you come from
whatever nonsense you believe there's a
place for you here babe even if I turn
on generate take rat for instance this
fella tried to kill venting himself
before he may love the Empyrean wrath
uses a trio of swords perfect for
liberating appendages from tour so much
like his associate cal darius this
brutally efficient badass clawed his way
up a generous biting kids to become a
champion never far from cal Darius's
side is Atticus this cybernetically
enhanced hall is a pugilistic superstar
throwing haymakers that get stronger
with every impact and hey there's Audra
yeah she channel's the power of the
stars themselves to scorch her enemies
to cinders
watch your life C&E the former spy
master of the generate Empire is
ruthless with both razor home fan blades
and spreadsheets alive able to quote
strike and disappear before you can link
the Andes is the deadliest assassin to
the Imperium has ever seen perhaps
you're one of those unaffiliated free
people of Solace fellows colloquially
known as a robe like Raina the Rope
factions unofficial leader she uses some
weight cool text to shield her through
from danger isn't that nice of her my
kiss indeed you can be certain for
example she'll have whiskey Foxtrot bow
of course you are familiar with the
clothes of the rapid deployment core
since you are one well even though
whiskey was from an earlier failed batch
of troopers he persevered and became a
fierce independent warrior in his own
right hey we'll speak about the black
sheep of the family mics are the real
deal move on tell that right there is
four ND and she's some kind of
multi-armed psychic burger store she
channels powerful magic like energies
and has been clinically diagnosed as
that crazy
no less unusual is chained convert
enjoyed ethereal partner and cries for
magical genie for crying out loud and
while Horrocks doesn't love being bonded
to a punk-ass kid he does love
unleashing a medley of fantastical
energies to keep his hatred will you I
totally love you sorry that's weird and
Toby cute adorable Toby just don't say
that to his face he's super insecure
about me but he hides it well inside his
custom-built metal replete with a crazy
powerful rail gun and shield
and then we have the UPR the United
peacekeeping republics the smart
protectors own some idealistic nonsense
let's begin with yeah let me just stop
you right there I shall do you PR for
years I know all about these clowns we
ship this bit no you're gonna love it
smart first there's Montana a lumbering
pile of fun whose considerable both
allows him to soak up hurt for his team
he also wields a fire and ice viewing
machine gun and loves hugs then you've
got his super best friend Oscar Mike
comes Jeff touch me touch me boutiques
hugging is stupid and for stupid people
he prefers related to his fellow man
with bullets and laser-guided airstrikes
hell yes I to tell me more flattering
crap computer guys moving on let's talk
about Benedict this fine feathered
fellow was blood from his perch when the
Morrell see invaded his roost he feels
his rocket launcher with an eagle eye
you see what I did there
you're losing me attend to allow me to
present galilea the so called rate of
bliss is brimming with dark energy that
she can unleash in torrance sucking the
very life essence out of anyone unlucky
enough to get in her way she alpha has a
really full sword but come on dark
Energy's hunting with the end which
brings us to our spiritual leader
captain Trevor Gulf a respected
commander and capable tactician got
wheels both charisma and shotguns with
equal effectiveness I be remiss not to
mention the eldren this topic collection
of astronomers mystics and space hippies
believe that the universe should be left
alone to run its course but don't think
that makes them pacifists these nature
lovers have teams just look at thorn
this Ranger once roamed the jungles of
Edmond are killing the ever-loving crap
out of any interlopers who strayed into
her realm he hired her gave her a bath
and now she smells much less like a
campfire
now boulder on the other hand he may
smell like a peat bog but handles that
shield and broom forged acts like a
champ and will gladly separate anyone's
head from their torso if they threaten
this land Nico is well a mushroom he's
great at healing Nico devotes her is
it's it's time to restoring all which
can be restored and throwing daggers at
things which cannot oh it's Kelvin how
ice of you to stop by see what I did
there I stuck that's because Kevin looks
just like a Ledge esta qalam privileged
shards that'll send that chill down your
spine Ennis
no appreciation for good humor finally
we have melka a high-ranked Eldred
operative she bites with a crazy scary
monster arm that she can reshape by mere
thought alone of course you could always
devote yourself fully and completely to
the last light consortium just take a
look at a few of our best and brightest
only some of whom are insane robots
worse there's Phoebe who for whatever
reason puts her intellectual capacities
towards the high octane blood sport of
competitive sword puppetry then we have
Marky you disgust me he's a high society
cybernetic sociopath he manufactures
adorable little robot out was that blow
up and he even ate his gun bindal bane
for crying out loud top that
have a look at dry bone this prosthetic
lien ass spider has a lot to be proud of
whether he's leaping from the top buckle
or taking some RLC to the mat l-drago
makes up here some opponents on the
battlefield and when he summons the
power of this Guardian dragon spirit all
his powers to come amplified with fiery
energy now I know phantom please but
I'll admit that you want this full timer
on your side during battle as no one is
better at draining enemy shields Buffy
of yours raining down mortar shells and
banal mouse fails summoning black holes
that assume everything around them not
bad for a stupid old skin bag and hey
who's got two thumbs and is about to
introduce himself this guy's and I don't
have any thumbs so you see there's a
place for everyone in the LLC even
monsters like yours truly so whether
you're securing the future of energy on
picture us economists wept hell's gates
of bliss or exacting wild I pageant
against Fred Danes generated Miriam and
is for Elsie nightmare pals there's
always something for badasses to do and
solace that ass is not unlike yourself
so how about it why not join the best an
alvian last company in the universe with
the last night consortium your future is
as bright as it is compulsory in
transmission
Oh like that think you can stick to the
script this time